Do have
uh important chats early on.
I wanna be a cool dad.
I don't wanna-
No no no no.
No one wants cool parents.
We just-
we gonna be boring.
And don't forget why you're doing it.
Yeah.
We need something in our lives
that bigger than us
and it will outlive us,
carry on after we've gone.
We will, alright?
We have loads of plastic bags
in our kitchen drawer.
Do try
to be patient.
I'm never gonna find a kid
Andie is gone.
You kidding?
She only come on the site yesterday.
What sort of-
They go so quickly!
It's like trying to get Glastonbury tickets.
And you should be prepared
for a bit of disappointment.
Hmm.
Why is everything so hard?!
Don't overthink it.
What am I supposed to do with a boy, Jase?
Society already fills him with confidence.
How can I compete with society, Jase?
It's bloody everywhere!
Do, do practice
your parenting skills.
Yeah.
It's just a bit of football in the
park with some kids.
Football?
Just a bit of football.
That's good.
That's fine.
Don't lose your sense of humor.
Happy?
Yeah.
Then why have you got your head
in your hands?
Huh?
And do...
Shut up.
...always
be there for each other.